now  oh look at that devastation  just wants to get out there magnus  carlsen is about to lose this match in  three rapid games  and that means he's not going to win the  tournament  yeah imagine the two leaders today  pragnanda and carlson both losing in  three games almost unimaginable  have we ever seen magnus lose in three  games  i mean  i mean i actually i can remember him  losing in three games  but uh i mean it's not like aaron there  we go it's a result he resigns he offers  a handshake to the great shakria and  mamadiaro who played just some fantastic  chance today to win the match  against magnus crossland and shake  everything up in the oslo esports cup we  do not know who will win this tournament  now but it's  most probably not going to be magnus  carlsen let's go to savannah to get some  reactions  [Music]